welcome back this man as well whose work
we all know and enjoy from the league
back in the day on FX and also from so
many animated features that my kids
would be so excited that I'm meeting
Gunther from saying and then professor
poopy pants from Captain Underpants and
then many of the adults out there I'd be
thrilled to know that douche from the
sausage party is right here on the show
man with range and the writer from
Netflix is big mouth Nick Kroll good to
see you good to see you as well I nail
that intro you did it's what a story duh
what a storied career it's been you have
range I do it is but it is so funny to
think I do like what one thing I'll do
and we could do it afterwards if you
want is I love for friends I'll do it
and I'll do a voice memo of Gunther I'm
taking it for the kids I will do that
I will take you up on that yeah kids
loved sing thank you immensely
I take full credit for it no it's so I
really actually really love that movie
too it's very sweet and and cool and and
yeah it was great it was very weird how
often do you get paint my kids loved
sausage party you get that you know
you'd be surprised
yeah well you know it's like it was so
wrong it was right yes it's so dirty
it's the second time I've played the a
douche that's right I was on Parks and
Recreation you've done it on network
television
the silver screen on the small screen
I've been a douche and I think let's be
honest on the league I was week-to-week
a real yeah I was a real douche yeah and
so ya know it's it's been it's what a
storied career but no it is it's great I
honestly do love being able to do stuff
that are specifically just for kids and
then stuff that you know goes it goes
into more adult territory so now that
the league has been done but by the way
I can't believe it's three years do you
still do fantasy football or do you just
did it for the show you know we were on
a we had a league in the league so all
the guys and and and ladies involved
with the show we were in the league and
then to be honest I haven't played since
I get random like people asking on
Twitter if I want to join their league
and I'm like I don't want to join some
random people's league but then I'm like
none of my
friends have ever asked me to join their
league are you serious I've never been
asked to join a league and now it's now
I think I figured out how to live a life
without being a fantasy now I'll just
say because sometimes if you're just
doing it for work
yeah or you're doing something about
something you don't want to do it in
recreation yes I think that's sort of
what happened was like we did it was fun
while we were shooting the show and then
when I was done I was like yeah I think
I'm out I think I'm ready have not
invited you what the hell I don't know I
feel like you might be in a league with
some of my buddies which which ones I
don't know I feel like there's like a I
want to say there's like a Riggle league
and stuff like that or my girl hasn't
invited me cuz he's I think he's a
little frayed he asked with you
how many leagues are you in right I mean
currently I'm in three leagues Tom and
one with my poker buddies that I want to
win desperately more than any of the
other course yeah well good look it's
not like yeah this sounds like an
episode of yes the league yeah another
one is a charity celebrity one of Jerry
Cantrell of Allison chain huh and
another one is one that I just randomly
entered with my kids online Wow on ESPN
how are you doing on that one uh we're
doing pretty well today weigh in they do
weigh in and on occasion I will veto
they're weighing in like it's just it's
funny like even if it's just for kids
yeah I still have to yeah I jumped out
and I jumped out just as like all of the
more like a fan duel all of those things
are they still are though still popular
week to week probably not as prevalent
as when right as we were leaving that
was like blowing up and then I feel like
maybe it's settled down a little bloated
yes literally but yeah I haven't played
but I think the league is now on Hulu it
was off all streaming services right and
now it's back on Hulu so if people want
to watch me be a just one of the most
acidic human beings on the planet they
can go check that out we call that a
hero name zero exactly and then there's
also of course Netflix his big mouth
we'll get to that in a second here with
Nick Kroll his uncle drew you were an
uncle drew yes what was it like being
around all those NBA players doing
comedy it was the most fun it was like I
got a call being like do you want to go
be in this basketball movie too uncle
drew the based on the you know the Kyrie
Irving
animate item web shorts and I was like I
thought that I mean I thought those were
super funny I think and and they were
like you want to be in that movie with
Chris Webber and Shaq and Lisa Leslie
and Nate Robinson and Reggie Miller I
was like yeah I want to I want to hang
out with all of those people and I want
to talk smack and I want to like you
know because I was at the Reggie mill I
was at then I was a Knicks fan growing
up I was at the Knicks Pacers games I
was at that game when Reggie went off on
spy on spying the Knicks yeah I knew
yeah I was there and I was like you know
a kid watching my dreams crumble in
front of me so to be on the bench as the
opposing coach watching Reggie try to
try to heat up and not and not hitting
some threes and just be smacking away it
was so fun and that was you know this
was this that was last summer
Kyrie the trade had just gone down it
was a fascinating time to be around
someone who was so deeply at the center
of his of the basketball universe and
and all and and then and then for me
just being able to hang out with Shaq I
mean I'm sure you've hung out with he is
he is there's certain people who you're
like well you're so talented so you get
to you know people are interested in
what you have to say but there he's
deeply charismatic like there is
something about that guy and he was
really sweet and nice and would happily
chat with me or he'd chat with a PA or
whoever he just was remarkable he really
is he has I know I mean I mean he's he's
one of my favorite people I've gotten to
meet in this business yeah me too I
really like he's also like he's scaled
up like 25 percent you know you can like
scale a photo you drag the corner and it
just like makes it like the same he's
like scaled up version of a
regular-sized person and I think it's
just that like I think it's a dude who's
been that large his whole life right
he's trying to figure out how to put a
room at ease from the day from like
probably the age of 10 on and and he's
gotten incredibly good at interesting
that's an interesting way to look at it
Nick Kroll here on the show so did you
give Reggie the satisfaction of telling
him that you were in the house yes
moment I did and he got a real kick out
yeah why did you feed that beast
it was sort of like I was like yeah you
know you know because for me it was just
like I gotta I gotta be honest man I was
at that game and he was just like oh oh
you know for him it's a pleasant memory
I don't know if I drop the same on
Patrick Patrick Ewing I probably leave
him alone but it you know I it was it
was really fun and I got to play a
little ball I mean not well but I get to
play a little bit with those guys and
now you did do that cuz I know you
played high school for basketball
yeah did you really get out there and
yeah we pick up you know is in the end
of the movie we get in the game me and
rel and and but we got in there and we
had some free play and I have like a
moment where I have a breakaway layup
and and and Kyrie wanted to block it and
he didn't get it and I was like ice
court you know I basically I mean I
scored on Kyrie would be extending it
but but then I was like all right I'm
feeling good let's go play some D and I
tried to Diop Kyrie and that might have
been a mistake did he cross you over you
know I didn't fall down I take I take
that skirt I take great solace and like
he didn't break my ankle I didn't fall
down he meant he did manage to get by me
and dunk on me just maybe but it was so
fun it was great I mean it's just like
it was just a dream to be able to get on
the court with those guys and and even
to play with them but to just be on the
court when you are at when you see what
they're doing because then we had all
these other dudes who were all like
college players who were all the extras
and other guys when you're that close to
those folks watching them play and then
watching like Kyrie you know you watch
them do like layups you watch the spin
he's putting on things he's doing some
scientific like geometry stuff that's
unbelievable and you're watching like
Lisa Leslie watch him and you're
watching these pros what like learn from
each other was really cool and Chris
Webber in this movie is made up
hilarious he is so funny in this movie
and that was he was another guy for me
because I you know I came up watching
that that fab 5 team was yeah I'm so she
gave me oh that's my school Wow so that
must have been I watched you know how
you watch sporting documentaries or
sporting a vocal over again
every time I hope that he doesn't call
the timeout huh and no and he does every
time he does it every time bye
but it's it's a shame that that is what
obviously you know Mick that gets
brought up because what he has done
since then and how he handled that
moment and he is straight-up really
hilarious he is he's so funny in the
movie and I he was another guy who I
really truly enjoyed like because I and
I'd never met him before and I had no
sense of him you having your head it's
like Oh Chris Webber like what is he
gonna and then and you hung out I hung
out with them and he was he's incredibly
kind nice warm thoughtful and to in
whoever he talked to and I'm telling you
the performances bananas but and also in
the movie they poke fun they're like
don't call any timeouts like he he has a
sense of humor about it all which is you
know and they go after Shaq for the free
throws it's fantastic so let's talk
about big mouth Nick rolled you and a
great cast John Mulaney who Mantzoukas
who obviously has some some League
yeah CNA oh yeah as well Maya Rudolph
Jordan Peele Fred Armisen I mean I could
keep going on Jenny slate well what do
you enjoy about this show on Netflix
based on me and my best friend from
childhood Andrew Goldberg and and when
we were 13 going through puberty and
Andrew got just whacked over the head
with puberty and I was a late bloomer
and so it started there and then it
became we built it out with our friends
all these boys and girls at different
stages of it and then also like you know
all the stuff that comes along with
puberty like hormone monsters the ghosts
of Duke Ellington of course I remember
that from my high school yeah Duke yeah
we go to Duke Ellington it would voice
by Jordan Peele
we visited a house when I was a kid that
that was the at one point owned by a
Cole Porter and so I was like oh that
would be funny to have the ghost of Duke
Ellington he's he's so funny and it's
just crazy it's just like this really
very I think honest super dirty
portrayal of what it's like to go
through puberty sort of nostalgic
looking back but it's current-day so
it's really what kids are going through
everyday about the feelings and emotions
that you have
of and desires and stuff like that and
how do you navigate it and and you know
we've it's this the second season just
came out and because on Netflix it can
be bananas I mean it's just crazy which
leads to a question I don't ever really
ask a guest who inspired the voice of
the hormone monster Oh Andrew my my
Andrew called me one day and was just
like so we have this idea for like you
know this kind of like hormone monster
cuz they were talking about amongst of
friends of like you know you have that
thing that there's that thing that's
like a hormone muscle yeah it's a
hormone monster said to me like we have
this idea for a hormone monster and I
just immediately was like Jojo they do
and it felt like it's not based on
anybody a lot of people online have said
that it's Will Arnett or diedrich bader
that did sound very or Nettie yeah I
mean I love both of those guys they're
both incredible talents yeah I couldn't
like I couldn't have thought less about
either of them and doing the voice it's
really in a way based on I did a
character on Kroll show named Nash
Rickey who was like an 80s metal band
who had a song his big hit was called la
deli and it was just all about the delis
around LA if you want to go out it's a
great you know go on YouTube check out
la deli but so it was Nash Rickey was
kind of a Bret Michaels kind of
character okay
and that's where that's where the
hormone monsters voice came from and
then I do the coach coach Steve was like
the gym coach he's never quite matured
Lola this tank of a girl how does that
gym coach sound like he's
you know we all had that like gym coach
who was like a nice sweet guy but you
know never quite progressed too far
beyond coaching middle school basketball
yeah
and he's he's deeply illiterate he's
also the sex ed teacher turns out yeah
yeah that's not very good
no it's maybe a commentary on the state
of sexual education here oh my gosh big
mouth co-creator writer
star Nick Kroll I'm gonna definitely
take you up on on on doing the Gunther
voice for my kids you got it no problem
I soaked right yeah you guys need to see
Sam you guys don't have children did you
not see singing McConaughey McConaughey
is amazing it now you guys record this
stuff separately recorded separately I
saw him at the premiere at Toronto and I
met him briefly I was like hey man he's
like hey how you doing and he was nice
enough but like just you know like
meeting 20 people I'm sure he looked at
my face thought I was an agent and then
and then and then a couple minutes later
he comes over he goes hey man you're
Gunther and I go yeah he did some line
back so he's like P power and I was just
like he's like you're here my kids love
you and it was just so cool and then I
got an email from him and he signs off
his emails play live signed our boy a
live stream live is the only movie segue
I could have I like it order me on
Netflix this Friday big mouth season to
come back Nick Kroll I shall please do
please Nick Kroll on Twitter check him
out the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience